i told you my friends and i like pulled
together some eath bought a couple nfts
right yeah one of them was a mutinate oh
yeah and it was like we needed eth in a
pinch or something in order to it was
like 10 of us coordinating 10 dudes to
all do the same thing it's [ __ ]
impossible right so we wanted to make
this purchase and i was like ah [ __ ] it
i'll just i'll send the rest of it and
then we'll even it out later so i did
that
bought the ape and then just sat on it
for a while and kind of forgot about it
and now i own like 30 because i own 30
of the fund or whatever you know that's
what i contributed over everyone else
and now this thing have you seen the
mutant names we bought it for four the
floor right now is 14. it was 16 like
two days ago 54 grand this [ __ ] jpeg
is worth
i can't do math
[ __ ] insane that's ridiculous do you
ever get the feeling though that it's
like it's like it is worth money but
then it's like fake yes of course it's
yeah it's all [ __ ] [ __ ] smoking
mirrors it's just
i i don't you know you don't know what
it is right but it's definitely a giddy
feeling to make a correct bet and even
if it's not like actual money yet right
because this could just tank tomorrow
and then like [ __ ] it's still it's still
like uh like a little
feeling like we wake up every morning we
check the floor like is it going up
people they buy the board apes they buy
the serum and it turns them in but
there's this there's m1 m2 and m3 serum
m3 is the rarest you can turn your board
ape into like a one of one mutant right
and so these things now
there's like four left or something like
that and the first one sold for over
three million bucks and the guy did a
live stream where he turned one of his
board apes into a mutant name and now
the second and third have also sold the
second one was for like over four
million and now the third one
was for like six million or something
like that it's absurd and so every day
we wake up and there's like more news
and we're like holy [ __ ] but anyway so
we're talking about it all the time
amongst this group right because we're
all like jokingly like really into
apes now you know doing stupid nft bro
talk and then my buddy sent this tweet
from this guy being like i just took out
a big loan from the bank in order to buy
more apes personally i think that's a
really bad decision and all of the
replies were like you go man dude so
smart so smart bro all of them not one
of them was like are you sure taking
debt to buy a jpeg congrats dude i hope
i hope you guys make a bazillion fake
money and then you have the opportunity
to convert it to real money well half of
us are like dude let's just sell it we
want to be laughing at this not
the ones being laughed at when there's
nothing goes to zero you know what i'm
saying we want to be like well we were
one of the people that profited off the
dotcom boom you know yeah yeah i mean
you know hey profit's profit okay you
don't have to take a ton that's what i'm
saying but then half of us are like yeah
but dude what if it goes to 50. you know
now that you say this um
i'm just gonna uh
i'm gonna sell everything i own and buy
by just all apes no don't just stop
there go into debt yeah you're right
you're right i'll sell everything i own
67 is the floor on board apes 234 000
the cheapest one that you can buy i was
reading some article about how uh
the board abia club is like it's
hilarious because as far as like the
features and the social club aspect and
all that they're like this [ __ ] is just
fizzled out into just a discord and it's
all people that just own apes and like
are just in there being like dude it's
going to the moon